welcome to auction school will you give
me 20 will you give me 29 what 5,000
what five on a mom and five to nothing
he would have been done doing 313 Lauri
told by our number one doodoo here we go
Ragan row the Missouri auction school
was founded in 1905 it's the oldest and
largest auction school in the world
it trains auctioneers in every aspect of
the auction profession and is known as
the Harvard of auctioneering introduce
the item as 410 dropped to five I'll
give you the five and then go to six so
we start every morning at auction school
with group drills daddy bothered about
the motivated butter bidder 84 rancor
happy
just like an athlete would warm up we
need to warm up very good okay give
yourself a hand good job at auction
school the most important aspect is that
auction chant at a hundred on inventing
three-mile beating that booze nap you
know it in their free now for you
through it all a bit not twenty five
twenty five its soul the very foundation
of the auction profession I'm a twenty
dollar bit in now thirty nine thirty
will you give me thirty I'm a twenty
dollar bid okay let's try that the
auction chant is two numbers the money
that you have bid and the money that
you're asking for I have one dollar bid
now - now - will you give me to the two
dollar bid now three now three would you
give me three I'm a $2.00 give me twenty
where you give me twenty feel that now
look you know thank you
I said that's that good job and as they
sell more and more those filler words
will slur so it'll move a little bit
faster send me a little bit or not one
on one button I do these everything we
use everything and Adamic things
everything's ending we give is
everything important - I'm 41 here we
give imported to 140 - thanks sir on up
over hundred eight hundred Autoport
sold 375 and that's what creates that
nice smooth rhythm chant rubber baby
buggy bumper basic rhythm okay learning
the auction chant in a classroom setting
is important but you're not really an
auctioneer until you get to go to a real
auction and sell real items - real few
times over the six hours of the TV
six hours or so by hours your way so the
student auction you never know what's
gonna come up for sale and so you got to
be ready for anything
first time slot seventy-five you got a
stack of three turtle got an old
tablecloth jumper cables very useful
black looks like in another stack of
turtles lot number six six three is
remain clean so one of the most
fascinating aspects of the process is
the transformation that the students
make throughout the program so often
when they first come to the school
they're hesitant they aren't sure what
they're doing a lot of them are
frightened even once they get up and
they sell and they realize yes
I can do this I can really do this you
can hear it in their voice I'm an
auctioneer
Dino didn't as when he had lain with you
is witty noises have way to give
yourselves a hand great job
that was really good good job okay now
let's do